today's topic uh we both got corona
what are we talking about
[Laughter]
i don't even know what you know what
you're up [ __ ] you why are you hungry
i'm gonna tell you why
[ __ ] you because this is real because
this [ __ ]
went halfway across the world and where
did he catch it
here that's right that's right i was i
was on all sorts of planes
i was on america corona airlines you
know what i'm saying packed in like
sardines
didn't catch corona i traveled to a
couple european countries
didn't catch corona i stay home for
three months i'm not even going to
grocery stores i'm just staying home bro
all day
bro bro no bro
i did not leave my home i did not see
people
other than preach we go to the bank one
time and
we get first i had allergies
then that allergy switch into some other
[ __ ]
listen allergies out it's like when a
girl tells you she got an itch around
her coochie
you got herpes don't be lucky you know
how
like people don't say that they got the
the corona yeah what do you say
uh you have to are you scared about
corona no no i'm immune
they don't say that that's really
not immune but you know the thing is
like yo listen
i lost 35 pounds in the big of it i lost
35 pounds i completely get it man
i got covered body height
[Laughter]
forget summer buddy coleman body [ __ ] i
didn't wear it out here walking without
a mask like cough on me
i'm trying to lose some weight and you
know the thing is people are going to be
there's going to be some people are
going to be [ __ ] on us because you
should be laughing about that
because because there's some people that
died yes like i understand that
okay i was actually
close to it i almost went to the
hospital my fingernails were purple
i had it worse than him i had everything
i was drinking
i have everything i have everything you
wanna know that's not funny because i
texted me like how you doing he's like
i'm all right
purple fingers yeah purple fingers i
didn't want to alarm you
no i know because every time you feel
you felt something like the first three
months that that
that that that that [ __ ] happened this
[ __ ] that we all live in
you were like oh [ __ ] i got itchy throat
i was i'm not gonna like i was not gonna
tell you like
yeah i'm dying you know what's crazy
though once i had it though i knew i had
it
yeah and your symptoms were weird oh no
me i had full fledge everything not
smelling is a [ __ ]
tasting weird hey man i'm glad you're
not dead
i'm glad you're not dead too yeah cause
we got a lot of money to make hey you
got that right
listen it's not gonna be the same it's
not yeah just preach it's like
a run a church what yeah just happen
it's gonna be the yeah it's gonna be the
difference it's gonna be the the the
bull back i think you can't do it you
can definitely run a channel so you can
do it as well oh i know i can i was just
but it's going to be different hell yeah
this ocean gonna be different yeah
you're not gonna make the kind of shadow
we're making right now
no we're not no we're not and we're
making cheddar
it's just crazy it's just this man
and people are acting like 2020 2020 is
gonna be over and everything's gonna be
done
no it's not yeah we got we got this
gonna be going on for a while i don't
know how they're gonna handle this
because like with new strains and all
that
they got trains i thought this was a
virus no it's weed it's kind of
strange it's kind of like the flu right
you know the flu comes everywhere you
got to get your your vaccine for the new
strain and everything like that
they got trains like that i don't know i
don't know what they gonna do man
i'm not man and taking the test was
unpleasant bro when they [ __ ] stuck
that rod into my nose
it made me understand women i compared
it to having like a skinny penis shoved
in a girl's pose like that yeah
yeah yeah whenever guys and side note
guys cut your nails what do you mean
you know when you you down there and
then you you know yeah
you if you have like sharp ass teeth
what is this random sex advice that
you're just giving because it just feels
like that in your nose when they go in
there they just get me just tap the [ __ ]
out of your
your nose island you know what i mean
they just stop the [ __ ] out of it and
then it's not even that
it's these [ __ ] turn yeah they
twist it oh
yeah like a purple nurple on this [ __ ]
that nurse touched me in place i know i
could be touched before
and i'm coming out with my own little me
too no we can't cut that [ __ ] out
i'm not cutting nothing you can't i felt
violated you can't
even though this person didn't know they
were doing that the first time they
didn't tell nobody
the first time no no because yo
no no bro they went so deep in my nose i
said no the wrong hole i look i look i
look at her like
first i was like yeah whatever in the
mouth okay and after that she was about
to put it in my nose i was like
you're going to use the same [ __ ] that
was in my mouth in my
nose okay that's kinky but i'm with it
and then she went in and i'm like [ __ ]
i never gagged from my nose before you
know i gagged
from my nose bro bro i was clutching the
chair so hard just trying not to move so
you can get that [ __ ] out
but like for the rest of the day my nose
is off like i felt like the test was
worse than the virus
i'm not collecting i had all these
symptoms and i felt the same
my nose was trash for like three four
days no it's just about my my nose was
already transcended i hate it so
but yeah i know it was yeah it's just it
was unpleasant
from a to b i understand the
[ __ ] that don't want people i
don't understand the people that don't
want to have all these things clothes
and [ __ ] i understand it i do understand
it
yeah i understand people you know what
even if i had it and i had it bad i had
it
i had it bad it's like i understand
i understand both sides of the story
yeah i understand
not to extreme you know what i mean i'm
not gonna say like you know i understand
the people that say that you know it's
all because of bill gates that's not
what i'm saying but i understand both
sides of the story
even if i had it so i think i think for
me me personally i'm not worried about
the virus for myself but it's just the
people around me i have responsibilities
so to me it's just like thinking about
them and the fact that they're at risk
that's it my parents my sister
yeah absolutely yeah that's that's my
concern so i think it's it's a tough one
for me
but i think it's just necessary so yeah
anyways we're recovered that's how we
think the height is so sometimes if
we're taking highlights and you guys
don't know why maybe it's because we
want to break or maybe it's because
something's going on
you know you don't have to know yeah but
you know as long as we can and we enjoy
it we're going to keep making content
for you guys so
um just know it's either we're not able
or we just don't want to at the time and
that's not fun for you guys because you
guys expect a daily dose or anything but
you know um like you guys know health
matters yeah but would you would you
rather
have us making content that we don't
feel like we're there and we just give
it to you
like some you know some [ __ ] you put in
the microphase yeah and then your
microwave is like bb
because i think it's going to give us
longevity i think what's going to give
us longevity is that we're gonna do it
the way we want to do it yeah i imagine
if
there comes a point where you don't want
to do these kind of videos we'll do
something different but then you ask me
you're like yo
is it like hey i'm out of it yeah
we got to do what we got to do it is
what it is yeah you know a priest needs
a week or two
off i'm like cool let's do that i need a
week or two off i'm not married to money
that much where i feel we need to make
content and
i think your subscribers want us to both
be really into it so yeah
do what we have to do so no
couldn't because she said i'm not
married to money and i was like i am
yeah you got two marriages going
oh damn [ __ ] thought you was
lawyer they didn't know how low he
really was
and we have merchandise go on that if
you want also one discord we chill there
sometimes
yeah more than me but you know what i'm
passionate about every game we
do dungeons and dragons we touch we talk
foreign